we begin this morning with a major
winter storm that is battering part of
the east coast with blizzard conditions
and hurricane force winds
states of emergency have been declared
from virginia to rhode island snow could
fall as fast as five inches per hour in
some spots
millions of people could face from one
to two feet or more of snow and it's not
just snow and ice that concern road
crews many places do not have enough
plow drivers so clearing highways and
even airport runways is a tall order
this morning more than 3 500 flights
have already been canceled at the
nation's airports today at least one nhl
game has been postponed because of
weather
we begin our coverage with mololengi in
boston where they are getting it this
morning mola good morning
well good morning jeff i know you're a
buffalo guy so you're probably used to
this sort of thing but i think even you
might be impressed with the snowfall so
far where we are right here it's coming
down at a rate about one to two inches
an hour with no let up in sight at least
not until tonight somehow someway this
storm is impacting much of the eastern
seaboard and if you live in one of the
hard hit new england communities and
frankly that's most of the region
probably a good day to stay inside and
that's not just stay off the roads but
you probably want to hold off on
shoveling your driveway shoveling your
sidewalks at least until tomorrow
because today there is a lot more
accumulation expected
what started out friday night as light
snow turned into a full-on winter blast
overnight with the heaviest snow likely
still to come up to 30 inches could fall
in parts of massachusetts which would
make this one of the biggest snowstorms
on record enough for boston's mayor to
issue a snow emergency on friday this is
likely to be an intense dangerous storm
with heavy snow high winds and whiteout
conditions those conditions are expected
throughout the northeast the national
weather service is warning of near
impossible travel at times with snowfall
predicted to pile up at a rate of up to
two inches an hour connecticut's
governor implemented a travel ban on
tractor trailers light and fluffy snow
is
nice for skiers and it's a better on the
power lines
but a lot of this is going to be wetter
snow especially along the coastline
there's an added challenge for plow
truck crews trying to keep up with so
much snow the pandemic has reduced
staffing in some areas meaning more work
with less help right now i have more
pieces than people to drive it new york
city residents are being urged to use
public transportation in order to keep
streets clear for plow trucks we could
expect
up to one foot of snow but you know
mother nature has a tendency to do what
she wants from the carolinas to new
england the storm system could create a
travel nightmare along the eastern
seaboard on top of the more than 3
thousand flights canceled today another
1400 were grounded yesterday if you live
in an area that
it looks like it will be dangerous to go
out in the morning please don't please
stay put
as the storm approaches local hardware
stores are struggling to keep must-have
items on the shelf i didn't find any
salt today hopefully tomorrow i'll find
some salt
back in massachusetts owner joe deegan
says he has only a handful of snow
blowers left normally i get somewhere
between 90 and 110 units and this year i
got 11.
and that's all production problem
again certainly a good day to stay
inside as officials are warning and to
sort of encourage that there are
countless closures and cancellations
everything from roads we heard the
interstates are closed to tractor
trailers in some states including here
in massachusetts some parking areas are
closed to allow plow trucks to come
through
facilities are closed some states are
closing coveted testing and vaccination
centers so if you're thinking about
going on you probably shouldn't but
certainly something you want to check on
before you do jeff
good advice mullen not only lived in but
grew up in buffalo but lived in boston
it was there for the record snowfall in
2003 which was 27 inches
uh sometimes i feel like it falls you've
seen it all
yeah i think so molar thank you very
much appreciate it